more than anyone
who do you think trump actually listened
to
in his ear more than anyone who were the
people he said you know what thank you
bro
there's my point uh i would say his
daughter i would say kellyanne conway i
would actually put kellyanne conway up
there i
really think you trust kellyanne conway
like tremendously
i'd probably put kellyanne conway at the
top uh i don't know about junior i think
daughter yes i think
junior's girlfriend uh kimberly i think
he would actually take
feedback from her because she was the
former wife of newsome i think
she would take the feedback i'm not
saying feedback because you can always
get feedback i'm saying
did he have a concept no like someone
who's like dude i'm having a rough day
i need to talk to you well he wasn't
close to the human human he wasn't close
to any of the former presidents he
wasn't close so it's like
you know it's i don't he had a there
might not be that person i guess
is the answer mattis was a good guy to
have kept again
going back to it i'm telling you i'm not
disagreeing with you but i'm telling you
right now
the reality of it is i would still
tolerate that personality to not have
something like this take place
tax is going up i would still tolerate
this personality
you and i don't get to dictate someone's
personality
okay you don't get to dictate someone's
personality yeah you hope the person's
character's solid like i'm not
compromising character don't get me
wrong i've been around a lot of people
in business
the moment i sense character there's a
line right there i'm not crossing there
you showed we can we have business
relationship but there's a limit to how
far we'll go doing business together
not crossing that line with you we can
have a drink we can have a conversation
we can do all that stuff great
deeper than that probably not
these policies taxes going up corporate
from 28 21 to 28 capital gains going
back up all that other stuff where's
that money going to to the government to
do what to spend 1.9 trillion dollars
spending money like
you haven't earned the right to earn my
respect to get pay you more taxes
you got to earn my respect for me to
raise taxes for example
if you are for example let's just say
you're one of my uh entrepreneurs i
invested in
hypothetically you are someone that's an
entrepreneur i invested in
okay matt and i are investors in your
company
you keep coming back saying i need
another 5 million i need another 10
million i need another 20 million i need
another 40 million
imagine you keep coming back just wanna
ask for more money and i'm like what'd
you do with the last five million i gave
you
what'd you do with the last 10 million
we gave you what'd you do with it
company hasn't grown
you ain't grown up 20 what the hell am i
doing reinvesting back into your company
now flip side
i talked to my board and i told them
board here's one thing i'm not okay with
i'm not doing this i just want you guys
know this so we have to kind of figure
this thing out right now we got a
three-hour call about it you know what
the board said dude what do you want to
do
you know why because there's results
so if i go to the board and i said i
need another 40 million dollars to do
what we want to do with the company
they laugh if i'm not growing they say
no problem how much you need 40 million
let's go get it because we're growing
you want to raise taxes and you haven't
proven
that you've done right with the last 100
billion a trillion we paid you
you have not earned the right to raise
the taxes yet
you just printed another 1.9 trillion
dollars that's
five trillion dollars danielle the
martin wood conversation we had last
week
five trillion dollars in the last 12
months you want to you want to raise
taxes
so this is this is exactly why
i offered a 20 tourist tax for the state
of california new york that we talked
about
it's the opposite take care of your
workers
take care of your job creators this is a
slap in the face so
entrepreneurs already had it hard the
last 12 months due to covid and now you
want to kick their asses you give
everybody 1400 bucks
but the job creator is like dude how do
i come up with this money
support me a little bit think about me a
little bit i lost my restaurant i lost
my dis
that's what we have to be thinking about
not hey how you doing let me see that
cut oh where's the wound give me the
salt
how's it feel huh don't worry about it
it's all going to work out you got
another cup don't worry about it it's
not going to work out no bro i don't
trust you
yeah so i don't know that that to me
um it doesn't sit well uh to do that
especially at a time like this man just
let
people recover before you say let's kick
everyone's tail
yeah i may be wrong look i've been wrong
many times in my life and i'm very
comfortable with it
but when i see something like this and i
think about the small business owner
that's doing his best to feed the family
and support a family of 10 plus
i want to empower him as much as
possible because he has proven
that he's made america better you have
proven you've made america better
mario has proven he made america better
mario is the highest paying guy in his
family
and mario's lineage if you see what
mario came from mario's not supposed to
be where he's at right now
he's not neither are you neither is he
neither am i
we did okay how did that happen we need
to reward
folks that are doing their parts so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you